[موسيقى]
ان جون هنا في شمال غرب سوريا المنكوبه
حياتهم مرهونه بحبل نجاه اخير يتمثل بفتح
المعابر الحدوديه مع تركيا كي تعود الحياه
شبهه طبيعيه بعد زلزال قضى على البشر
والحجر
لكن ما هي اهم المعابر الحدوديه بين سوريا
وتركيا وايها يعمل ليكون شريان حياه لاكثر
من اربعه ملايين شخص في شمال سوريا
معبر باب الهوى هو حاليا المعبر الرسمي
الوحيد في شمال ادلب لعبور المساعدات
الانسانيه الى سوريا بموجب قرار مجلس
الامن الدولي تسيطر عليه المعارضه السوريه
معبر باب السلامه في منطقه اعزاز شمال حلب
تسيطر عليه فصائل المعارضه السوريه معبر
جرابلس في ريف حلب تسيطر عليه فصائل
المعارضه السوريه ايضا
دوليا المنظمات الامميه طالبت النظام
السوري بتسهيل مرور المساعدات الى مناطق
المعارضه من دون قيد او شرط اما مجلس
الامن فسيعقد الاسبوع المقبل جلسه لمناقشه
امكانيه السماح للامم المتحده بارسال
مساعدات الى شمال غرب سوريا عبر اكثر من
معبر حدودي
بدوره النظام السوري اعلن موافقته على
ايصال مساعدات للمناطق المتضرره الخارجه
عن سيطرته واستردد تركي بعد ان قالت انقره
انها تدرس قرارها محاسن حضاره العربيه